je m'appelle sébastien room je suis
ingénieur spationautes
j'habite dans la station spatiale
internationale je suis un peu moins
connu que thomas pesquet mais je
travaille un peu plus que lui dont je
vais vous dire comment j'ai vécu moi cet
après-midi de la station alors ça
commence comme ça à 15h04 vidéo de
présentation tmx 15h10 pascal des
charges
le transhumanisme éliminer la maladie et
demi né à la vieillesse éliminer le
handicap éliminer la mort bref des
réponses à l'homo sapiens devient l'homo
cyborg et les plantes vous me parler via
twitter pour me dire ah yan first y
tient il faudra penser à équiper tous
les humains qui souffrent vivent sur la
planète terre je pense qu'on doit
recevoir des tweets j'ai soif après qui
valait lire ici peut-être mal trump il
est souvent sur twitter qu'ils pouvaient
arroser les plantes
alors moi ce qui m'a impressionné c'est
que les capteurs qu'on aura encore vont
permettre au tableau de bord de ma
voiture de savoir que je suis malade
avant que je ressens que moi même des
symptômes et mieux on pourra être réparé
alors une future visite chez le médecin
par visiteur une cyber visite ça se
passe directement entre la puce qui gère
votre santé et le central serveurs de
médecine générale
bonjour j'ai mon oeil droit qui marchent
plus ah oui vous l'avez redémarrer
oui vous l'avez débrancher cinq fois en
maintenant votre bois foncé oui oui bon
alors attendez je me connecte abbott web
info sante.fr ah mais dites donc les
plus sous garantie mais non vous n'avez
pas pris l'extension de garantie
donc j'ai obligé de vous envoyer en
atelier de vous faire faire un devis ou
alors vous souscrivez le global clair et
je vous fais un changement à neuf tout
de suite mais c'est plus cher
ou alors vous jailbreaker votre oeil et
vous essayez de le réparer vous même
vous trouverez des tutoz sur internet
alors personnellement moi ça m'est
arrivé dans les ss au moment de voter
parce que bon on a beau être en haut ça
nous empêche pas de vouloir donner notre
avis moi je voulais voter sauf que ma
puce de vote ne répondait plus alors bon
bah pareil c'est un peu loin donc gelé
restée moi-même je les ai craqué j'ai
même découvert d'autres fonctionnalités
sur la piste de vote notamment on
pouvait voter plusieurs fois
pourquoi j'ai voté plein de fois je vous
dirai pas pour qui
mais bon il a gagné
et à ce moment là il parle de transit
man is me dit que c'est pour augmenter
l'homme
moi j'y voyais un petit point de peur
augmente et l'homme et pascal défaire je
le dis ouais voilà augmenté l'homme tout
ça fasse mais il faut se méfier par
exemple pour avoir une meilleure mémoire
et là je me suis dit pour une fois que
l'homme réfléchit à augmenter autre
chose que vous voyez peut-être on
pourrait donner une petite chance aux
transhumanisme et puis quand on regarde
bien à chaque fois que l'humain à
inventer quelque chose doit découvert
quelque chose quoi que ce soit que ce
soit la massue en bois ou la fission
nucléaire
eh ben ils sont nés tout le temps
immédiatement servi pour rendre le monde
plus beau c'est tout aliment est donc
tels les x men se transigent humanisme
va nous donner des super pouvoirs
alors moi j'ai déjà un super pouvoir je
vous le dis en fait quand un gars ont
fait un bisou dans le cou
ça me fait des frissons partout et je me
connecte directement avec les étoiles
si vous pourrez essayer tout à l'heure
si oui 15h31
la vidéo simone pâris de bollardière
méfiez-vous de l'obéissance mince non à
non sans déconner on apprend aux enfants
à obéir depuis qu'ils sont tout petits
fais pas ci fais pas ça vient ici mais
toi là attention prend pas froid ou
sinon gare à toi mange ta soupe aller
aux toiles et dans touche pas ci fais
dodo dit papa dit maman haddad à propos
de kader à cheval sur mon billet et vous
simone paf vous dit
méfiez-vous de l'obéissance bon la sncf
vous a écouté au lieu de faire des
horaires bien nets ils se sont mis à
faire n'importe quoi et de 17h03 aider
23h08 et désobéissance ils les
respectent pas
mais simone je voudrais vous remercier
parce qu'en fait je viens juste de
mettre des rideaux dans ma cabine sur
les fesses et en fait j'ai hésité entre
le jaune et le rouge pendant longtemps
visiblement le choix que j'ai choisi
tout le monde trouve ça moche et je me
sentais pas très bien ce jeu là imposer
un peu aux autres et là on vous regarde
en bas je peux vous dire que j'ai
compris j'ai compris qu'il y avait des
combats bien plus importants que les
couleurs de rideau et du coup bah ça
nous inspirait dirais que j'ai appelé
thomas pesquet et je peux vous le dire
on a pris une décision tous les deux dès
la semaine prochaine le thomas pesquet
mois et un chien on va aller se mettre
juste devant une fusée qui décolle
15h52 constance je suis constant ce
voyage 18 ans je suis fille formidable
avec des parents formidables dans une
maison formidable damian nian nian hier
la bon je me suis dit ok je sais c'est
le moment de me lever pour aller prendre
un café
vous êtes et et puis la pape dans ce que
vous dites oui on va parler de corps et
d'esprit
je me rassois hélas allons vous nous
dites que vous n'avez pas choisi votre
corps bon je n'ai pas trop mal tomber
moi non plus j'ai pas choisi je pas trop
mal tomber non plus enfin dans le corps
parce qu'alors pour l'esprit comment
vous dire moi je me demande toujours
pourquoi on a inventé le mot mais c'est
très intéressant ton idée sébastien mais
on va faire autre chose
je ne sais pas encore si je préfère le
côte-rôtie ou châteauneuf du pape je
trouve que le téléphone est une
invention géniale mais j'ai horreur de
mon servir d'ailleurs j'ai jamais
j'adore les plantes vertes je trouve ça
magnifique et apaisant et paradoxalement
j'ai un incroyable talent pour les faire
mourir je sais que si je bois trop je
vais avoir mal à la tête mais je bois
trop quand même
et là tu poses la question que se
passerait-il si ton esprit venez dans
mon corps bon
alors je n'ai jamais essayé donc je ne
vais pas dire non directement 1
mais si tu es d'accord je préfère qu'on
prenne rendez-vous mais genre je
préviens tu peux aussi passé à
l'improviste on va se débrouiller on va
manger des pâtes tout ça mais je te
préviens quand je le disais plus tôt
c'est pas très bien rangé alors ensuite
tu nous dis qu'à 18 ans qui n'a pas
toutes les réponses
bon rassure-toi des vingt ans on a
réponse est
et puis à 30 ans on ne sait plus rien à
40 ans on sait tout mais mieux qu'à 20
ans à 50 ans et plus rien non plus et
ceux qui savent tout nous agace à 60 ans
on sait tout mieux mais on se souvient
plus très bien mieux que 15 à 70 ans on
sait plus rien on commence tout juste à
se moquer et enfin je dis ça mais bon
moi j'ai 30 ans 1 alors je ne sais rien
enfin 30 ans et demi et là tu poses la
question que serait l'humain sans
l'erreur
bon bah là moi je vais être honnête un
sommet erreur j'aurais jamais été
spationautes 1 j'aurai fini comédiens ou
un truc menaces du genre et après tu te
demandes le monde serait-il plus beaux
sont l'humain alain on réfléchit sont
deux minutes vue de l'espace
la beauté de l'humain on la voit bien on
peut pas la louper un c'est vrai que la
terre était un peu trop verte alors on a
su virer tous ces arbres qui ennuyait
tout le monde c'est vrai que la terre
était un peu trop blanche alors on a su
virer ces glaciers c'est banquise moche
et puis c'est vrai que c'était un peu
trop bleu alors on a su la recouvrir en
tout cas une grosse partie de nos océans
d'une bonne grosse couche de plastique
artistique une oeuvre contemporaine la
plus grosse de l'histoire de l'humanité
un merveilleux patchwork de merdier
agglutinés auquel chacun et chacune peut
participer si il ou elle le souhaite
une oeuvre participative alors comment
participer modestement avec un mégot ou
un coton tige ou en devenant grand
donateur
on donne ce qu'on veut il y en a qui
donne de l'acide il y en a qui donne des
perturbateurs endocriniens
il y en a qui donne des boues rouges il
y en a qui donne des déchets nucléaires
il y en a qui donne des pesticides
chacun donne ce qu'il veut c'est comme
ça et ça c'est grâce un peu à tout le
monde
donc ceux qui ont plus évidemment donne
plus
mais si vous même vous n'avez qu'une
piles usagées ou un sac en plastique
donné l'important c'est de participer à
l'oeuvre humaine constance lui posait la
question l'erreur et à lummen et tu
réponds oui bon et après tu dis que les
humains apprennent de leurs erreurs et
ne refont jamais les mêmes erreurs mais
ça je pense que c'est parce que tu as 18
ans et que doivent pas fait encore les
mêmes erreurs mais patience
en tout cas constance de là haut
j'aime beaucoup tes souhaits et tes
rêves de tolérance et je les partage
16h07 l'heure de la vidéo ted 16h vite
l'heure où pascal change la taille des
sous titres sur la vidéo tête
alors du coup moi j'étais assis trop aux
vins trop au pardon du coup j'ai pas lu
les sous titres mais j'ai trouvé que le
monsieur avait une belle veste noire et
il avait une super à toute une super
attitude il avait un beau sourire alors
à un beau sourire parce qu'en fait ça
c'est le sourire qu'on a quand on pense
aux étoiles est ce que c'est que ce
merdier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous en faites pas assez
c'est un technicien et cg pas important
non c'est vrai enfin là vous vous dites
en euros
parce qu'il est jeune et beau et mignon
tout ça mais les autres là où alex manu
cédric ils sont plus jeunes et beaux
tout mensonge ou des techniciens
non non non alors tout à l'heure c'était
le sourire vers les étoiles et ça c'est
là dans ce qu'on a avec nos voisins et
c'est eux
on aime les étoiles venez on est sur la
planète terre on à la technologie casse
toi toi avec tes fleurs on chez toi aux
mêmes rêves ou rencontrer pour partager
notre savoir
ta gueule va mourir ailleurs les
connexions avec les étoiles et la
connexion lesquels voisins
17h28 françoise gri nous parle de nous
les femmes car vous le savez peut-être
je sais pas si on vous l'a dit mais il
existe des inégalités entre les femmes
et les hommes
mais il ya des changements il ya des
évolutions bon là par contre vu de
l'espace où on ne voit pas bien bleus
s'avancent pas si vite que ça
alors s'il vous plaît les jeunes
contribuer à régler ça 1
et les autres visez-vous parce que on va
jamais y arriver sinon on va ça mais
laissez-les on faire pour ou alors on le
fait ou alors on se tait mais il faut
qu'on avance là-dessus
alors à vos soeurs à vos mères à vos
grands-mères à vos voisines à vos amis à
vos copines à vos épouses à vos attentes
qu'est ce que vous allez leur dire qu'on
veut viendront vous dire qu'elles vont
faire un truc formidable ou tout
simplement qu'elles vont faire un truc
qu'elles ont envie de faire
et bien vous allez leur dire vas-y et si
jamais ça réussit vous lui dirai bravo
tu as bien fait et si jamais ça foire
vous lui dirai bravo tu as bien fait
parce que c'est en faisant qu'on devient
formidable continue recommence enfin
fais ce que tu veux et vient me voir à
chaque fois à chaque fois que tu doutes
parce que moi aussi je doute mais pas de
toi
et le jour où vous doutez de l'autre
et tant que vous y êtes dit ça à tout le
monde on dit ça car globalement quand on
vient vous voir et on vous dit j'ai
envie de faire quelque chose mais j'ai
un peu peur d'agir c'est votre soutien
qu'on vient chercher c'est pas votre
expertise frileuse et dubitative alors
encourageons nous encourageons nous ça
coûte pas cher et ça rend tout possible
après il ya une vidéo alors les jeunes
tant que vous y êtes régler aussi la
question des réfugiés s'il vous plaît
arrêtons d'en parler et accueillez vous
voulez parce que bon je sais ça vous
fait beaucoup de travail mais mais comme
vous le voyez nous n'y arrive pas on
n'est pas capable faut nous forcer un
peu pour nous forcer parce que si
possible si vous pouviez régler cette
question avant que y ait des
extraterrestres qui arrive parce que
sinon on va vraiment passer pour des
cons
18h07 jean louis normandin
qu'est-ce qu'on a ri
j'ai je peux je ne peux rien dire jean
louis c'était c'était fabuleux j'ai
entendu ça de la station je ne sais quoi
je ne sais pas quoi dire
liberté dignité ça va me faire cheminer
longtemps donc je passe directement à ma
conclusion
alors oui oui pour reprendre votre
formule jean-louis ayez les pieds sur
terre et la tête dans les étoiles
car les rêves peuvent être porteurs la
tête dans les étoiles pour garder les
yeux et le coeur ouvert bien plus que si
on regarde par terre ou son propre
nombril la tête dans les étoiles pour
garder de la curiosité pour le monde qui
nous entoure
ici à côté de vous mais aussi un peu
plus loin la tête dans les étoiles et
continuent à penser large si vous avez
un talent fait en sorte qu'ils ne savent
pas qu'à vous même et si quand vous
regardez tout le temps vers le haut vous
voyez plus rien et ben baisser la tête
et vous allez voir plein de gens
formidables
des personnes formidables et des
personnes qui sont tout aussi
importantes que vous tout aussi
importante que le oui parce que vous
êtes vraiment des personnes très
importantes comme toutes les personnes
qui vivent sur cette planète
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]